mais vous savez peut-être envie
maintenant d'adopter un serpent
peut-être je sais pas - les arts ces
nouveaux animaux de compagnie qu'on a vu
dans ces sujets en tout cas rester avec
nous on va parler d'économie à présent
besoin vivons sarif reid alors on
s'intéresse à la santé des entreprises
et à cette initiative nationale déclinée
dans les yvelines pour leur venir en
aide et éviter notamment le dépôt de
bilan or en cours qu un bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes et vous êtes
également bénévole 1 au sein du centre
d'information sur la prévention des
difficultés des entreprises dans les
yvelines c'est exact absolument à la
multi alors comment cette initiative est
née elle est en fait allé initiative du
président au tribunal de commerce donc à
versailles qui est comme tous les
tribunaux d'ailleurs sont assez désole
de voir les entreprises arrivée au
tribunal à ces exemples ce qui veut dire
qu'effectivement il ya un problème de
communication il ya un problème aussi de
2-2-2 d'hésitation de la part des
entreprises à venir s'adresser au
tribunal est donc cette c'est une
association failles qui existent au
niveau national qui a été créée donc à
cette initiative à versailles pour que
l'on puisse rencontrer les entreprises
qui commencent à avoir des difficultés à
vendoire le siv tard avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard voilà parce que c'est tout le
cfi timo tout le problème c'est un petit
peu de la même manière que quand on va
voir un médecin un peu tardivement voilà
il vaut mieux effectivement rencontré
des gens qui sont compétents pour
pouvoir discuter vous êtes une dizaine
de bénévoles au sein de cette
association tout à fait quels sont les
profils des bénévoles alors les profils
bénévoles sont de plusieurs de 4 nature
différente en fait il y as pour être
assez complémentaires donc il y a des
des juges donc honoraire du tribunal de
commerce dont qu'il n'exerce plus mais
qui ont cette expérience des experts
comptables ou des commissaires aux
comptes des avocats et puis également
donc des experts de la chambre de
commerce ou de la chambre de métiers
donc au point de vue économique et tous
et tous ces différents corps de métier
vont être là présents pour aider ces
entreprises il faut cette
complémentarité absolument parce que
c'est on sait bien que tous les
problèmes une très grande diversité
problématique dans les entreprises elles
sont soit plutôt dominant juridique
dominante financière un peu des deux
d'ailleurs très souvent c'est important
aussi suivant la situation de
l'entreprise de connaître le point de
vue d'un ancien membre du tribunal de
commerce pour voir cette appréciation et
puis la chambre de commerce de soucis
donc sous les asperges à dire plus
économique ou même également je dirais
sur les contacts qu à la chambre de
commerce pour pouvoir aiguiller les
entreprises contre les entreprises font
face à de nombreuses difficultés on le
dit et surtout en période de crise nous
sommes allés demander aux saint
quentinois quel dispositif pourrait
aider les tpe les pme on écoute vos
réponses je sais patron parce que le
gouvernement s'est pas non plus alors
c'est là où est le problème il faudrait
déjà que le gouvernement sache qui est
des gens qui se penche sur la question
pour qu'enfin on puisse aider les pme à
s'en sortir et à l'information des
formations et puis à la question des
prêts qu'on pourrait en faire pour des
jeunes entrepreneurs qui se lancent je
pense qu'il ya qui a des fonds qui sont
mis en place par l'état et des
formations faire des formations des
suivis qui sont mis en place personnes
qui sont à la retraite
qui pourrait encore activé qui pourrait
leur être un soutien aider les
entreprises
dans leur démarche vers l'exportation
avoir un partenariat tout du long c'est
à dire que du début où on prend le le
produit jusqu'à la fin et en continuité
il ya un certain cadre supérieur qui
pourraient être partagées entre
plusieurs entreprises
ça aussi ça pourrait se faire
question à vous poser leurs encours
contre d'hawaï ans qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est un président qui vous
semblent plutôt bonnes oui alors toutes
les idées sont bonnes en fait non mais
c'est pas du tout politique ce que je
dis mais c'est vrai c'est donc votre
monde y suivant la problématique dans
l'entreprise chaque idée enfin lui une
idée peut-être la bonne je crois que
skate dans dans ce cadre cette
initiative donc des six pieds en fait
c'est une pleine forme en quelque sorte
de régulières auprès des entreprises
dont votre maudit suivant les problèmes
qu'il ya ça peut être de nature
effectivement pourquoi pas c'est une
très bonne idée aussi c'est existe
ailleurs le temps partagé donc pour les
cadres qui ont de l'expérience
ça peut être effectivement des problèmes
de trésorerie s'est très souvent des
problèmes de trésorerie mais le prends
une trésorerie plus exactement une
résultante plutôt qu'autre chose donc
effectivement le ces ip et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui est aussi des experts de
la chambre de commerce se sont d'aider
des gens qui ont une complémentarité
donc de vue et qui cherche surtout à
réguliers les entreprises qui sont un
peu perdus pour qu'elle puisse
effectivement trouver une solution le
matin justement c'était l'objet de ma
deuxième question là vous êtes là pour
aiguiller on a le sentiment qu'il existe
quand même beaucoup de choses pour aider
tous bords et les entreprises oui est ce
qu a pas trop de dispositifs aussi oui
alors justement c'est pour ça que j'ai
fini au moins un élément fédérateur
comme le ces ip peut tout au contraire
aider les entreprises je suis d'accord
avec vous il ya beaucoup d' aide il ya
beaucoup d'associations
mais très souvent pour les créations
d'entreprises ou pour éviter mais
rarement pour les entreprises qui ont
des difficultés
sachant des difficultés peuvent être
soit conjoncturelle soit structurelle
voilà et donc effectivement un organisme
fédérateur comme celui là qui est
d'ailleurs tout à fait bénévole qui est
de fonctionnement extrêmement simple et
extrêmement sous nous ne sommes pas très
nombreux et l'élément important parce
que les entreprises aussi hésitent à
venir nous voir c'est que nous avons un
strict c'est une obligation pour nous
d'ailleurs de confidentialité autrement
dit les entreprises qui sont là il rien
ne sortira 2 c'est à eux qu'ils
s'étaient eux de décider par la suite
mon chien ou simplement les aider vous
dites vous êtes bénévole vous dites
également vous n'êtes pas très nombreux
vous êtes tout de même joignable
absolument nous sommes joignables et il
ya effectivement d'aucun numéro qui
s'inscrit qui s'inscrivent donc là c'est
internet et une adresse internet voilà
exactement en fait nous sommes logés par
la chambre de commerce et donc toutes
les l'élise aller les entrevues qui sont
formés qu'ils ont entreprises se font
effectivement la chambre de commerce
donc ces entreprises que vous allez
aiguiller vers qui est ce que vous les
aiguilles et on vous parlait à des
problèmes de trésorerie on pense
notamment au médiateur du crédit a mis
en place par la banque de france au
domaine ça peut être voilà des produits
string des réponses au 8 août a fait il
existe aussi à la chambre de commerce
une communauté des financeurs où
justement comme beaucoup de financeurs
ben alors on sait pas trop à qui
s'adresser et suivant la problématique
donc il peut ya voir ça peut être un
fort développement ça peut être une
difficulté passagère peut-être plus
structurelle d insuffisance de fonds
propres donc en fait on ré aiguilles
voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle donc
il y à différents différents
intervenants mais c'est vrai pour les
problèmes financiers on intervient aussi
bien entendu on ne fait rien jamais
directement on intervient pour leur dire
allez à talons en tant que conseiller on
a l'impression que c'est assez
informelle ces rencontres est
confidentielle vous le disiez vous êtes
un peu les psychologues des pme en
difficulté oui exact et c'est on
s'aperçoit surtout pour les entreprises
sur 60 seul quand ils ont des problèmes
elles n'osent pas en parler à leurs
banquiers traditionnels parce
qu'autrement elles ont peur
effectivement d'avoir des conséquences
plus lourdes elles n'en parlent pas
toujours rose autour d'elle peut-être
même rarement d'ailleurs en famille pas
forcément et donc nous sommes des gens
puisque nous avons une obligation de
confidentialité on peut jeudi pour tout
nous dire mon peut nous dire beaucoup de
choses et on est là uniquement pour les
aider donc ce qui fait qu'il n'ya pas
deux il n'y a pas de traces qu'elles
n'hésitent pas à venir au contraire
monsieur là pour les recevoir est ce que
votre propre expérience de chef
d'entreprise vous aide à trouver des
solutions dont je rappelle que vous
gérez un cabinet d'experts comptables à
versailles qui recrutent donc f1 qui
emploie 80 personnes oui tout à fait
alors bien entendu nous sommes des chefs
d'entreprise qui nous adressons à des
chefs d'entreprise ça je crois que c'est
important aussi parce qu'on a souvent
tendance à considérer que les
conseillers entre guillemets ne soit pas
les payeurs mais aussi ne soit pas très
acteurs nous sommes enfin en tout cas
moi j'exerce dans une activité où on
emploie effectivement beaucoup de gens
donc les problématiques qu'on les
entreprises on les connaît très bien et
je pense que ça c'est un point aussi
effectivement kate est important il faut
pas oublier que j'interviens aussi dans
le cadre du cip et en tant que membre du
medef
a effectivement vous avez bien fait le
mentionner c'est ce que j'allais faire
ça ça change que d'avoir un
interlocuteur qui connaît le problème
oui voilà absolument parce qu'il faut
parler terrain on est là infiniment pour
parler de choses extrêmement pratique
nous sommes là pour aider les gens pour
essayer parfois leur faire dire un
certain nombre de choses qu'ils hésitent
même quand ils nous voient donc à dire
donc il ya un côté de communication
psychologique extrêmement important on
voit parfois des classes est dramatique
des gens qui sont complètement terrorisé
ou complètement tétanisé il faut les
aider
précédemment peut-être pas des exemples
est le plus marqué celui qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est une mésentente
donc entre avec un client important mais
pour lequel effectivement le chef
d'entreprise du coup donc darier pas se
faire régler et on essayait
effectivement de lui dire il faut
composer peut-être parce qu'il vaut
mieux tenir que courir et l'avocat qui
était là donc à aider beaucoup
effectivement à faire un petit peu lui
faire dire à sa tombe de choses qui
s'était véritablement passé pour pouvoir
trouver un début de solution et savoir
comment régler son problème parce qu'ils
arrivaient pratiquement une situation de
blocage et j'allais dire presque dire
suicidaire
une dernière question concernant le fait
que vous soyez donc trésorier du medef
dans les îles est-ce que c'est pas un
peu antinomique si on peut dire parce
qu'effectivement a l'impression que au
medef les entreprises adhérentes ont une
très bonne santé économique que tout va
bien et pourtant vous aider les
entreprises en difficulté oui alors vous
avez raison c'est l'heure que d'une part
l'immédiat territoriaux et en
particulier mais des départementaux ont
surtout des pme donc je dire comme
adhérentes à toutes les grandes
entreprises adhèrent aux medef national
ça c'est le premier point et puis
deuxièmement dans le cadre du net nous
travaillons que pour nos adhérents sans
être exclusif c'est effectivement la
priorité par contre niveau du cibc
entend bien entendu donc que medef mais
c'est aussi pour aider toute entreprise
quelle qu'elle soit quelles qu'elles
soient et quelle que soit la taille
d'ailleurs ça va de la tpe jusque
jusqu'à la pme alors en pratique pour
les chefs d'entreprise qui seraient en
difficulté et qui nous regardent on peut
prendre un rendez vous auprès de la
chambre de commerce donc on a vu des
informations qui s'affichait à l'écran
c'est un jeudi sur deux absolument c'est
dire que pour l'instant c'est un jeudi
sur deux
évidemment les rangs des vaudois qui
sont créés la vente parce qu'elle puisse
organiser et en fonction si nous avons
plus de demandes dont on essayait plus
d'entreprises effectivement qui
s'adressent à nous ça peut très bien
effectivement être chaque jeudi au fond
on dit quand même relativement nombreuse
pour assurer une rotation et c'est
gratuit et confidentiel c'est gratuit et
confidentiel
voilà on a fait le tour merci pour ces
éclairages avant de poursuivre cette
chronique de l'éco je vous propose des
fruits frais en lice de pause détente
depuis huit ans les vergers de gally
livre des paniers de fruits dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui la société
enregistre un millier de clients jusqu'à
paris les précisions valérie auribeau
elodie mois
comme tous les matins sébastien parent
avec la liste des clients a livré dans
son camion les corbeilles de fruits
qu'il faut préparer selon chaque
commande nous livrons des paniers de
fruits dans l'entreprise et les
entreprises peuvent les utiliser soit
par le principe d'un abonnement donc sur
une période déterminée soit par le
principe si vous voulez du one shot de
l'événement un conseil d'administration
une réunion commerciale ou une soirée
entre collaborateurs peuvent être aussi
l'occasion de partager des fruits frais
ce jour là sébastien commence à tourner
chez un client régulier le constructeur
automobile nissan dit vric deux fois par
semaine un vrai succès la corbeille est
souvent vide en fin de journée nous
avons des retours très positifs
les employés sont très contentes d'avoir
non seulement accès aux fruits
gratuitement mais en plus ils estiment
participer à une action de solidarité
qui leur permet de faire acte de don à
une association qui s'occupe de la
recherche contre le cancer j'en prends
régulièrement lorsque je suis au siège
social en même temps qu'on café est
bénéfique pour les visiteurs également
puisque quand je suis visiteurs dans
d'autres entreprises clientes je profite
également de ces fruits frais
clémentines raisins les bananes on n'a
pas souvent le temps de bien manger en
entreprise on est tellement chargé on a
tellement de choses à faire que c'est
souvent la solution de facilité d'aller
prendre un sandwich
de manger devant son ordinateur donc
avoir des fruits à disposition de
l'entreprise c'est une très bonne chose
pour notre alimentation
et pour être plus efficace en travaux
créé il ya huit ans le concept a fait
des adeptes les vergers de gally compte
un millier de clients sur paris et sa
région
il faut remettre ça en place ici la télé
fait soixante dix avec des fruits frais
pourquoi pas la chronique de l'écho en
tout cas qui se poursuivent avec les
infos en plus du soir oui l art en
continu avec les chiffres du recensement
dans les yvelines le département compte
plus d'habitants qui au long dernier
mais vous allez le voir saint quentin en
yvelines a perdu quelques centaines
d'habitants explications avec ce
reportage
il ferait bon vivre dans les yvelines le
département compte 2001 habitants
supplémentaires selon les chiffres
entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier 2013
d'après l'insee les yvelinois sont au
nombre de 1 million quatre cent trente
5448 habitants soit une augmentation de
0 13% en un an ces trappes qui
enregistre la plus forte augmentation
avec 760 habitants supplémentaires soit
une hausse de 2 56% la ville compte
désormais 29 1705 habitants son maire
guy malandain met en avant la bonne
desserte de la commune son dynamisme
économique et son offre de logements
manille connaît également une légère
augmentation
a contrario les autres villes de
l'agglomération connaissent un recul
voisins le bretonneux enregistre une
baisse de 1,43 pour cent de sa
population et compte désormais douze
mille 122 habitants de même à montigny
où le nombre d'habitants a chuté de 1,13
pour cent pour atteindre 33
1899 au 1er janvier idem pour l encours
guyancourt et la verrière versailles
demeure la plus grande ville du
département avec 88 1253 habitants la
plus petite commune des yvelines reste
sans surprise le tartre godrans avec 31
habitants cependant l'insee considère
qu'un comparatif sur cinq ans est
nécessaire pour apprécier la variation
de la population au sein d'une commune
ou
encore des chiffres pour cette chronique
et de l'écho à présent les chiffres de
l'emploi oui alors il s'agit de l'emploi
intérimaire e en ile de france pour le
mois de novembre 2012 l'emploi
intérimaire enregistre une baisse de
11,4 pour cent par rapport à novembre
2011 ceci sur l'ensemble des secteurs
d'activité avec notamment - 18,9 pour
cent dans l'industrie et -6 % dans les
services en cumulé cette baisse est de
10,9 pour cent depuis janvier 2012 dans
la région ce sont les chiffres du prisme
le budget du conseil général des
yvelines a été donc voté le 21 décembre
dernier nous en parlait en début
d'émission de ce budget primitif avec
yves vandewalle vice président du
conseil général des yvelines il nous
parlait d'un budget bien évidemment
selon lui plutôt bien être libre et
qu'il gardait ses priorités oui donc le
budget s'élève à un milliard deux cent
soixante dix sept mille euros une hausse
de 2% par rapport à celui de 2012 les
postes les plus financés sont les
transports on en parlait justement et
puis la formation au 1er janvier
certains prix augmentent d'autres
baisses un petit point s'impose oui
alors du côté des bonnes nouvelles
commençons avec ribéry exactement le
smic augmente de 0 3% le smic horaire
brut est désormais de 9,43 euros le rsa
revenu de solidarité active augmente lui
aussi plus 1,75 pour cent ainsi que les
allocations familiales plus 2,1 pour
cent enfin le plafond du livret a est
réhaussé de 25% il est désormais de 22
mille neuf cent cinquante euros c'était
une mesure a évoqué lors de la campagne
de françois hollande pour relancer la
construction immobilière notamment du
côté des mauvaises nouvelles wilfried et
rigueur du gaz et de l'électricité
augmentant les deux alors pour le gaz
une augmentation de 2,4 pour cent et
pour l'électricité plus 2,5 pour cent et
puis il faudra payer plus pour
s'éclairer exactement avez vous encore
des ampoules à filament chez vous bien
évidemment oui eh bien
elles vont être retirés des magasins car
elles sont désormais interdites à la
vente les ampoules à incandescence comme
on dit autrement dit à filament de 25
volts au profit des ampoules led fluo et
allogènes de rendez vous à présent c'est
la jambe haricots oui alors on part les
entreprises avec notre invité comment
créer sa propre entreprise par exemple
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles vous y aide en organisant des
après midi d'information gratuits sur la
création d'entreprise méthodologie des
commerciaux aidé à la création feront
notamment partie des thématiques
abordées la prochaine réunion se tiendra
jeudi 10 janvier de 14h à 17h à
versailles et c'est gratuit et on se
rend à la cité des métiers de saint
quentin en yvelines va concerne l'emploi
exactement alors la cité des métiers
vous aide à préparer votre candidature
avant de se rendre sur les forums
d'emploi parce que généralement on y va
avec un cv souverain et puis on a du mal
à se positionner à se démarquer surtout
enfin la différence aulas ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde comment présenter son
parcours ses expériences significatives
aux recruteurs c'est lundi 7 janvier de
14 heures à 16 heures à la cité des
métiers à trappes merci alice jeudi
prochain mêmes horaires la nouvelle
chronique de l'éco voici à présent le
rappel des titres de ce 3 janvier qui
ont été développées notamment dans cette
édition du 7 8 les chiffres de la
population entrer en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2013 ils viennent d'être publiés
par l'insee est sur une année a noté que
le nombre d'habitants dans
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise est en
légère baisse il est stable pour
l'ensemble du département un séjour
inter générationnel proposé par le
secours populaire des yvelines c'est le
premier du genre pendant une semaine une
quinzaine de personnes jeunes comme
moins jeunes a rejoint la savoie pour
passer les fêtes de fin d'année à la
niche est des fruits frais en guise de
pause détente depuis huit ans les
vergers de galles il livre des paniers
de fruits dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui la société enregistre un
millier de clients dans les yvelines
jusqu'à paris et puis une fête peut en
chasser une autre après noël le nouvel
an voici venu le temps de l'épiphanie
est les boulangers s'activent pour
préparer leur galette comme le veut la
tradition la frangipane remporte les
succès reportage dans une pâtisserie à
la verrière vous l'avez découvert ce
soir il est à revoir sur notre site
internet nous sommes également revenus
sur ce plateau ce soir sur la journée
mondiale du braille qui se déroulera
demain le combat de l'association des
paralysés de france pour le droit à une
vie affective des handicapés moteurs et
ils vendent val vice président ump du
conseil général des yvelines qui s'est
dit inquiet des avancées des discussions
autour du grand paris express et les
hésitations autour de la réalisation de
lax entre saint quentin en yvelines et
saclay décision du gouvernement sur ce
super métro attendu le 15 février la
galette des rois à l'iss vous avez déjà
acheté
vous en avez déjà mangé diva n'a trouvé
la galette du sud la brioche ou la
brioche c'est l'éternel conflit entre le
sud et le nord sur cette galette
frangipane en tout cas nous nous sommes
rendus dans une boulangerie de la
verrière reportage ouanna soudry et
anthony rech patrick jacques de dixmude
is it et non à wissant portage boire et
manger la galette à la boulangerie de la
verrière les pâtissiers ne manque pas de
travail surtout avec nos équipes qui s'y
rendent
et oui à la verrière on aime la galette
des rois pas d'originalité ni de
fantaisie la préférée de toutes celles à
la frangipane au départ la galette
c'était la galette à la crème d'amande
crème d'amande c'est une frangipane mais
sans crème au beurre sans crème
pâtissière pardon ce qui fait qu'elle
est légèrement plus bourrative
plus pur en amendes automatiquement mais
plus bourrative et les gens délaissent
un peu ça ils préfèrent la projet pal et
puis bon
on fait plaisir à la clientèle ont fait
en france j'ai pensé ce qu'ils vont
au maximum entre 800 et 900 galette se
vendent autour de l'épiphanie dans la
boulangerie de jean-pierre et malgré la
concurrence du supermarché la clientèle
ne désemplit pas sylvain lauton ne
dirait pas le contraire en 25 ans de
carrière dont 14 dans cette boulangerie
de la verrière
le pâtissier a appris tous les secrets
de la galette voilà la fève
cette année ces vols personnages de walt
disney là
le disque du dessus
voilà enfin on soude
le petit trou qui est important
pour enlever l'air qui est emprisonné
quand on a remis le
chapeau
chez taj faut faire un petit décor
qui va se revoir
à la sortie du four la galette devrait
reposer cinq heures avant d'être
enfourner sur une heure de travail si 20
ans préparera une centaine et pour
chaque galette acheter une bouteille de
cidre offerte de quoi régaler les plus
gourmands toi la
bouteille de cidre galette le week-end
s'annonce festif une fois de plus très
léger très léger toujours ressortir
défaite forcément je retrouve lundi
prochain pour une prochaine édition
pardon du 7 8 des 18 heures demain le
7-8 week end avec catherine mulato le
résumé complet de l'actualité de ces
premiers jours de janvier excellente
soirée